Recessions usually mean job losses.
And when a recession begins to end,
we typically see jobs
start to open up again.
After all, that's what happened
after the great recession in 2008.
Notably women made up a
large percentage of those
who entered the workforce
during that economic recovery period.
After the great financial crisis in 2008,
because family finances were so strained,
a lot of women entered the workforce
to support their families
when they hadn't been doing so before.
And at the same time,
we had a really, really
strong labor market,
which allowed women to enter
who hadn't been doing so.
Up until early 2020, women were
making gains for, you know,
the prior five years.
Women's labor force
participation had been growing
over the past 60 years.
In fact, things were going so well
that in January 2020, 2 months
before the Coronavirus
pandemic shut down the US,
women had outpaced men
as the majority of the
workforce for the first time in a decade.
This is a really good thing
because this is the
future of the workforce.
We are increasingly becoming
a services oriented economy.
But all of that progress was wiped out
when the pandemic forced everyone home,
disproportionately affecting
women around the world.
More than 12 million women lost their jobs
during the pandemic and
over four and a half million
have not returned to the workforce.
The impact of COVID is so severe
that it set the rate of US
female workforce participation
back more than 30 years
to the same rate it was in April 1987.
So while the 2008 recession
recovery may have worked out
for many women, this time,
women are finding themselves burnt out
from juggling unemployment
or working full-time remotely
with domestic roles.
Many have even decided to give
up their careers entirely to
tend to at-home unpaid labor
and their own personal health.
The burden of caregiving
with schools and daycare
still not fully open in
some parts of the country
is an added burden, especially on mothers.
So as businesses reopen
and employers are hiring again,
many women aren't necessarily coming back.
In a crisis that some
economists are calling the first
female recession.
Out in California two
of the best mechanics
working on Link Trainer planes are women.
It used to be during recessions
that women actually entered the workforce
to take care of their families.
We saw the same after World War Two.
And so this was a really unique situation
in that, rather than joining the workforce
to support their families,
they left the workforce
to support their families.
According to data from McKinsey,
more than double the number
of mothers found themselves
taking on an additional five
hours of daily domestic work
compared to their male counterparts.
Much of this can be
attributed to gender norms
across societies with women
bearing more of the burden
at home.
We know that when
there's a crisis at home,
whether that's a pandemic
or a family crisis
or a crisis with a child themselves,
it's often women that are the
ones to take on that care.
And so when we had these school closures
and daycare closures,
it naturally was women
that left the workforce at a faster pace.
What's different about this particular
recession is that it also affected women
across all pay levels
from minimum wage workers
to high level executives.
I spoke with a woman
for some of my reporting
who was a top executive at
Facebook who left her job
for childcare.
When you're at such a high
executive role like that,
you can't just go and
start working at a bar,
which is really where the jobs are open.
And when you have a competitive resume,
it takes more time to reenter.
And so she was expecting it
could take up to six months
or more to kind of get the
role that she was looking for.
Other women who chose
to stay in the workforce say
they were barely hanging on
while balancing multiple full-time roles.
Reshma Saujani is a CEO
of the organization,
Girls Who Code.
At the height of the pandemic,
she found herself overwhelmed
with juggling household
chores, caring for her sons,
and working on her nonprofit remotely.
I was doing the homeschooling
while I was running
my organization.
In between, I was doing the laundry.
You know what I mean,
doing the dishes, right?
Ordering whatever I needed on Amazon.
And so by the end of the
day, I was just done.
You know, I got COVID
and it barely registered.
You know, my liver failed.
I had acne on my face as
if I was like 16 years old.
And it wasn't just me.
In response to the pandemic,
Reshma is proposing a Marshall plan
to better support working
moms, including wage equity,
paid family leave, and
work retraining programs
for women return from maternity leave.
So, you know,
moms are not America's social safety net.
We're one of the few countries
that doesn't offer a paternity allowance.
That's come today in the
form of a child tax credit.
Today, the expanded
child tax credit is here.
But that was a revolutionary idea.
That's been met with a
tremendous amount of resistance.
As a mother, a single mother,
like you need to be there
for everything for your child.
I was working at 311.
I got a call.
It was like an emergency call.
And my supervisor's like,
you can't use your phone.
So if people need you,
they have to call like the office
and you would get connected
through your supervisor.
My child ended up at the
hospital and I'm in the middle
of the floor, at her
desk answering the phone,
I'm instantly devastated,
but I'm also embarrassed,
frustrated, aggravated that
I had to get this phone call
like this, in front of
this woman, standing here
in the midst of everybody.
I ended up losing the job
because when you're out,
you have to call in and tell
them kind of what's going on
or the reason for your being out.
And at that time, I couldn't
even talk without crying.
That really kind of
threw me off as a person.
Burnout isn't just something
that happens at work.
It's something that happens
when you're, you know,
a domestic childcare provider.
And so if you're trying to
do both of those things,
people's mental health suffers.
This stress is compounded
during the pandemic with one
piece of research stating
that working women
have reported increased
levels of depression by 83%,
compared to 36% of working men.
Crucially, this can
impact a woman's ability
to progress in her career.
And when women are
underrepresented at work,
companies are less incentivized
to provide them the support they need.
Women do a tremendous
amount of unpaid labor,
almost 86% of the household
chores and the childcare rearing
is done by women.
And so you simply can't raise
your hand for that promotion.
You can't start that business.
You can't take on that nursing degree
that you've always dreamed about
because you have so
much happening at home.
And this is why we have
enormous levels of poverty
when it comes to women of color,
because they're in low paying jobs
and they're not getting
the support that they need
to thrive.
So I lost my job, stopped paying rent.
We went to live in the shelter.
One of the things that I did
with a lot of my free time
was volunteer at church.
We wanted to show the scriptures,
like, so if people
didn't have their Bible,
they could just look up on the screen.
I figured out what device to
use and what program to run it.
I had some help, but a
lot of it is me running it
and doing it and implementing it.
One of my friends,
she saw that I had a
good hold to technology.
On her friend's recommendation,
Tanya soon applies and gets
accepted into a coding bootcamp.
It's a program where
you don't pay upfront,
but it's also like an unpaid thing.
So there was no income coming from there.
So I'm in Pursuit, struggling.
Things are moving very, very quickly.
When it comes to the coronavirus,
I'm stating the obvious to everyone here.
Covid hits.
I had to shift my whole life
to make sure that I supported
and covered my children.
I have to leave early every day from class
so I could get my daughter
and so that she could go into the shelter.
We're told to stay indoors, stay in place.
But I couldn't because I still
needed to do the classes.
And I was having issues
with the wifi they gave me.
So I would go to my church.
I think the thing that broke so many of us
and it still breaks me now is
it didn't seem like anybody cared.
It didn't seem like anybody
was saying, gosh, the moms,
you know, what are we gonna do?
Because this country
doesn't function without us,
but we just kind of ate
it up and kept going.
Still many women found themselves
without any other
options, but to persevere.
I had a lot of outside stressors.
There's a lot of assignments
that I wasn't able to complete.
I get through the program at Pursuit,
I'm able to move on to the next steps
with my fellow students in the class.
And I'm not found job ready,
but I still started applying to jobs
just like everybody else.
One of the alumni posted a job position.
I applied.
I got hired at The Knot Worldwide.
When I got the job, I was crying.
I was crying.
My boss, nobody knew my situation.
I didn't tell them like,
that's not something you tell
people you're interviewing.
No, you just go to see
confidence and competence.
That's all you're going to see.
While Tanya found success in the end.
This isn't always the case for
other working moms struggling
to find a work-life balance.
And there's still plenty to
be done from both the private
and public sectors to better
support working women.
And then we ask ourselves, you know,
why do we have a declining birth rate?
Well, the reality is it's
too expensive to have kids.
And so it's not that people
don't wanna have them,
it's that they can't.
A lot of companies pride themselves
on offering paid parental leave.
Some of these companies
offer moms six months,
dad three months.
Why?
Or when you take, when you're a guy
and you actually take the
parental leave, it's frowned upon.
We've seen companies like LinkedIn
and other tech companies kind of offering
alternative childcare.
Last summer, for example,
some companies offered summer camps.
And then in the public sector,
we've seen Biden making a big push
for what we call soft infrastructure,
which would be universal childcare
for children ages three and four,
as well as childcare subsidies
for those from zero to five.
The current child tax credit
that was passed during the
pandemic offers families
up to $300 in monthly payments per child.
As part of her Marshall Plan
for Moms' proposal, Reshma
is calling for these credits
to be extended indefinitely
among other benefits.
Making the child tax credit permanent,
getting affordable childcare, you know,
passing paid leave once and for all.
The second piece is
really working, you know,
on the private sector and making sure
that we build a work environment
that works for parents
offering parental leave,
offering flexibility,
finally getting equal pay for equal work.
With so many things going on,
we have to choose what our
children over our jobs?
Like, we're capable.
And if we're paid enough for
the value that we do bring,
we can actually be able to do a bit more.
Even as Congress makes moves
towards financial assistance
for working mothers,
there are also many other issues
preventing women from fully
returning to work in person.
From sexual discrimination to harassment,
to microaggression at the workplace.
And then it's the men who have
face time with their bosses
and are getting the promotions
and are being noticed.
If employers really want to create
a greater culture of belonging,
it does require addressing systems.
And that takes money.
COVID has given us this opportunity
to look at our society and say,
you know what I want to
build it back better, right?
Like this is broken and it
is okay to acknowledge it.
It's not just for moms, but it's for dads.
It's for millennials who
don't want to have kids,
it's for everybody to be like, uh uh.
We are actually going to
redesign the workplace
so that it works for us.
And we have to recognize that we have
a once in a lifetime
opportunity to do that.
So while financial help
and flexible work
accommodations can be helpful
in supporting the female workforce,
the solution really begins
at home on a societal level.
We still have inequality at home.
We're never gonna have
equality in the workplace.
We didn't go through hell and back
to stay exactly where
we're at when this started.
Let's use this opportunity
to fix things for once.
Let's finish this fight,
like once and for all.